if you trust the government is going to
do the right thing I think you're alone
in that respect in November 2015 the
National Security Agency lost the
ability to directly hold information
about the phone calls of millions of US
citizens this was all thanks to the USA
Freedom Act passed last summer but don't
get too comfortable while the change is
significant the NSA can still collect
and store your communication from the
internet and social media
so all those selfies you've been taking
and all those online chats with friends
yeah the NSA may have them stored up
somewhere it's hard to say where they
store them but in the future they'll be
stored here in these nondescript
concrete buildings the sleepy town of
Bluffdale Utah we asked the NSA if they
could show us around the complex but
were promptly turned down because the
site is a secure facility they may have
understandably been a little spooked
since Edward soon revealed all that
spying on Americans that they were
involved in the NSA data center is
primarily server space where they have
large rooms with racks of servers that's
Pete Ashton of ex mission an internet
service provider in Salt Lake City
before Snowden revealed massive spying
by the NSA in 2013 Ashton was able to
get a tour of what was inside those
concrete buildings and he may be one of
the only people to talk about what he
saw publicly what did you see how did
you even get an invitation to go X
mission is part of Utah data center
consortium which was started by an
individual at the University of Utah
University Utah of course has their own
data center and they wanted to get
people together to share ideas and best
practices the data center consortium
included University Utah eBay or Cole
and it also includes the NSA and I think
the NSA participates you know just to be
friendly and probably to recruit because
whenever there's a thing at the
University of Utah where we're talking
data centers they go up and they want to
talk to the students to tell them what
they do and what a great job it is to
work for the NSA so they made that
invitation in fall of 2012 and you know
I heard it was a great facility and I
wanted to check it out so you walk in
and what you walk around and see on this
tour it was still under construction at
that point and I saw a lot of people
pulling cable they loaded us into a van
and drove us around first we saw the
facility kind of like from above and
they
they pointed out how it's divided into
two facilities that are redundant with
each other the questions they would
answer were very banal but we were able
to calculate the capacity just by
Counting the generators each of those
generators was like a two megawatt
generator and the head over 30 of them I
think wow that's a lot of power it is a
huge amount of power I think a megawatt
can service a thousand homes the tour
guide said that one of the reasons they
wanted to build the data center in Utah
was because of the patriotism of people
from Utah yeah that was one of my
questions is you know why why did you
come here and his response was the
electricity is cheap and the people are
patriotic and I read that as a code word
is that nobody's going to ask any
questions and you know that that kind of
sat with me uneasily that it in my
opinion patriotism is questioning your
government consistently the idea that
we're just sheep out here and we're not
going to care I think is you know even
though we're a very conservative state I
think a lot of people would bristle at
that idea okay so they put the
pillowcase back on your head and you
leave the facility what did you think
after leaving the facility what like
mold in your head I'd always heard the
myths that the NSA could read hard
drives and cracked all encryptions and
you know I asked him about that and they
just kind of laughed that off but as the
days went on and I thought more about
the facility and I thought more about
what Mark Klein had revealed in 2004 he
would reeled it in the AT&T data center
in the Bay Area that the NSA had an
intercept room where all the data
flowing through AT&T at that point was
going in and nobody knew what was going
on inside now that was something else
that was interesting about the tour as I
asked well where's your internet
connection do you have a connection to
the Internet at all and they said this
building is not connected to the
Internet so they have intercept points
around the country that I think they
pulled data off of those intercept
points and put them on their own private
network they definitely have fiber going
into that building but I think it's
completely air-gapped from the Internet
I started to realize that it's just a
data collection point that they're
collecting and storing as much data off
the Internet and telephone networks that
they can and they think that
if you ask for a warrant later to look
at the data that's okay even with
everything that's Snowden revealed do
you think that the average American
really understands both data collection
from the NSA absolutely not I think it's
a very hard thing for most Americans to
understand exactly that their data is
being intercepted and stored and a lot
of people would say well I'm not a
criminal I not a problem with it well
the thing you have to realize is you may
not be a criminal but giving that data
to other people and trusting them with
it
there could be criminals on the other
side if you trust the government is
going to do the right thing I think
you're alone in that respect